foreign
[Music]
Chuck why the emergency call to my
hotline because we left off a place that
has really put me in my Peak curiosity
okay which is we were talking about how
the death of stars seeds the universe
with the ingredients of life
which by the way was like just
incredible what a great explainer where
we you know talked about how Fusion
leads to a point where we get to iron we
can't go anymore or as I like to call it
absorption
and and then boom we have to explode
right yes yes and but then you this is
what got me when you said that and then
that is what when these elements go out
into the universe and they seed Stellar
nurseries and you know and they start
this process again and I'm just like how
does that even happen like how does the
process itself then get kick-started you
know
um okay so I'm sorry so a couple of
things let me come into that from a back
door okay so if you take biology class
and one of every biology class will
spend some amount of time trying to
Define life yes okay and it's hard
because we only have one example of it
right so it's it's hard to generalize
what life requires if you only have one
example of Life the day we find another
example of life
we can throw away the things that we
thought were fundamental to life
that happen to apply to us and just get
the basic bottom common denominator of
the two life forms that we know about
and if we discover a third life form in
a tenth life form we can more sharply
tune so for example this life need
liquid water well we know life on earth
needs liquid water but does all life
maybe there's liquid ammonia in another
place okay that matters I saw a comic
where there's a crashed alien Flying
Saucer in the desert right and the
aliens are crawling out and they're
saying ammonia
so just a little bit of a cosmic
perspective there right so life you
don't I don't think we know but often
what's bandied about is the idea that
life has a metabolism okay it it uses
energy it needs a source of energy so
that it can use the energy
and then when it uses the energy it has
to continue to replenish the source and
life needs a way to reproduce itself
otherwise it wouldn't sustain I guess
something can be alive but not ever
reproduce itself but in the full
understanding of what life means and
does on Earth
it has a metabolism and can reproduce
itself okay if you look carefully
at stars
they have a metabolism
they're born they live out their lives
they die and they reproduce themselves
so by some definitions even many
definitions of life
stars are alive
just putting it out there so in the
respect of life itself there is
there is a facet Where Stars themselves
fit the definition
very important definitions that's
correct and the reproducing themselves
is their gas clouds waiting for this
enrichment that then birth a next
generation of stars so it's it's just an
interesting way to think about stars
relative to how we've thought about
biology so now we can ask how you make a
star in the first place
all right well well first you got to get
a good Agent let me just tell you
because you can have all the talent in
the world but if you're not connected
correctly you're gonna have some issues
okay so some gas clouds have better
agents than others okay all right so
um there are two broad categories of
Galaxy out there one of them is
elliptically shaped and we call them
elliptical galaxy these okay and they're
sort of round and they don't have much
gas at all they ate up their gas back
when the Galaxy was born leaving hardly
anything left to make new generations of
stars okay we call those elliptical and
broadly again another is a very flat
version of a galaxy that has spiral arms
and we call those spiral galaxies all
right okay yeah clear and present all
right those are very inefficient at
making stars and they're still making
Stars today
they're as old as the elliptical
galaxies but they're still making stars
and they still have huge repositories of
gas
all right now I have a gas cloud minding
its own business okay all right
um there are reasons why a gas cloud
would just be happy to stay that way its
entire life but here's what happens
ah either a star blows up nearby
creating a shock wave that that
literally shocks the gas cloud okay or
there are other sort of waves that
relate to the maintenance of the Spiral
pattern and they're called spiral
density waves and the point is what we
have is you have gas clouds moving
through a region of the Galaxy that
because of this what's called a density
Wave It's compressed as it moves through
this region before it comes out the
other side gotcha all right and so
what's an example of that if you're in
traffic and you're driving down the
street right and then you sort of if
there's a slow-moving car with its
flashers on right it slows everybody
down yes okay and you work your way
around it and come out the other side
right that's a density wave in the
traffic
awesome if you see it from a helicopter
the entire traffic pattern is moving
because the car with its flashers on is
moving it's just moving slower than
everybody else so the traffic is moving
fast it slows down and it merges out the
other side that is a density wave in the
traffic It's A Perfect Analogy to what's
happening in the Galaxy except the
Galaxy doesn't have cars all right so
here's what happens if you shock the gas
cloud or create a density wave that'll
Force some compression little bits of it
will now be denser than other regions
okay if you're denser you have stronger
gravity near your surface than other
places do well I want to get that next
molecule that comes by and you're going
to attach to me
you're not going to be free-floating
anymore okay so all right I just added a
molecule to myself
and you didn't
with every extra molecule I now have
more gravity than I had before aha okay
and I start clearing out the gas cloud
because even if you tried
if I started before you I'm gonna win
because this is a runaway process for
all the new masks that I accumulate
based on the power of my Gravity from
before I now have even more more gravity
correct so more gravity gets breeds more
gravity
and this is a runaway process and so
when this happens you can trigger star
formation in a gas cloud
and typically there's a whole region of
the cloud that starts making Stars
and when you do that you make a star
cluster all the stars with the same
birthday
and uh it's fascinating how we used star
clusters to figure out how Stars evolve
it it's it's more fascinating than it
sounds like than I'm even explaining to
you right now it's just complete it's
the same thing as taking a snapshot of
civilization
and all you have is a snapshot right and
you have to figure out well how are
people born and how do they die you're
right are you born uh are we born in the
ground right shriveled and we bring you
out of the ground and then we feed you
and then you flush out and then over
time do you then shrink and then exit
back into another human being that the
time order is not obvious because we
don't have a video of this happening we
just have because we don't live long
enough we just have snapshots of
clusters at different stages of their
evolution and so that's another
explainer I'll get to that it's it's
very cool
but just I'll give you an example
everybody in a day goes to the bathroom
some one way or another but you don't
spend much time there well
um that's debatable debatable I'm just
saying
relative to other things you do you
don't spend much time there so a
snapshot is not likely to catch you in
the bathroom
art do only some people live in the
bathroom while others don't what does
everybody go through the bathroom so
these are questions we ask and we answer
them brilliantly in the history of this
exercise but my point is
um this triggering of the gas clouds is
what this shocking of the gas clouds is
what creates pockets of condensation
right pockets of convergence of matter
that then as they continue okay they get
bigger and bigger and bigger now
it'll keep doing this
the native temperature of the cloud
will sustain it to some level okay
but as it gets more and more and more
massive
there's greater and greater
gravitational pressure on the core
there is the point
where
we have ignition got you
thermonuclear fusions and ignition and
in that moment A Star is Born
and so that then stabilizes this against
any further collapse and it will
continue to
accrete material unless
unless the star is of a very high
Luminosity variety because you know what
happens the photons that come out they
exert a pressure unto themselves
and if you if you're Johnny come lately
to the party you just get pushed away
and so this is a fascinating point in
the evolution of a star because the high
Masters we see them
evacuating the pocket out of which they
formed
Pockets where the gas is not as dense
because first it absorbed up the initial
amount of gas in that pocket and anyone
who tries to make it later it ends up
getting pushed away sorry guys Club is
full Club is full guys
gotta put the Rope down guys listen now
I'm a big fan I'm a big fan don't worry
man I saw your latest work I'm a big fan
the club is full we got fire laws we got
fire laws man sorry no put your money
away bro put your money away I'm serious
and by the way this is the decades and
Decades of hard-earned telescope
observation brilliant people thinking
about what's going on there's the
thermodynamics of it the quantum physics
of it the the chemistry of it there's
all of this going on and that's why in
astrophysics we tap the expertise from
people of many different professions and
that's also why uh astrophysics is by
many myself included is considered a
Gateway subject to teach in school
ah so you can use that as a means of
going to and as a portal to go to many
different lands in science yes in
science the biology the chemistry the
physics the geology the geology on the
plants and of course we send Hardware
out there so if you're if you're an
engineering geek and love the universe
we got a place for you too so nice yeah
this has been my recruitment
PSA for modern astrophysics so anyhow
that's that's how we that's that's kind
of how it's done that's pretty cool I I
I I love it a fast Edition Chuck do you
know when I was in high school in my
chemistry class uh-huh I had asked as we
learned about the periodic table I said
when all these elements come from
both we find them in the Earth
that was the answer it would be a couple
of years later when I learned no we made
these in Our Stars right okay that they
were birthed in Stars first and then
became part of the earth as the Earth
formed
um and oh by the way
uh barring a bit from the earlier
explainer where the buck stops at iron
yes all right and by the way there's no
shortage of iron in the world and in the
universe and earth's core is primarily
made of iron all that comes from
uh the fact that once the star made iron
there it is it's a major part of that
the major part of that uh process it
makes the heavier elements it can still
make heavier elements it's just not
getting energy out of it right right so
there's a plenty of energy in a
supernova explosion to keep making
elements up the periodic table but
you're not sustaining the energy of a
star by doing it you're sucking energy
from the explosion and all the energy
that's already available to you so man
anyhow that's how it works Chuck some
that's how that works that's fascinating
I love it I love it it's uh I mean it
makes perfect sense and the thing that's
weird is that you have to think about
these in terms of atomic terms like
while you're thinking I'm trying to
think about this not in terms of like
actual things fusing like Lego you know
Legos are good that's a good future
because yeah you're getting close enough
then they just sticks right right but
just stick in there yeah yeah but yeah
but it's it's no yeah it's happening at
a at a at a time not only Atomic but a
nuclear a nuclear by the way the whole
universe which was all energy at one
point as the universe cooled that E
equals m c squared the energy becomes
the matter out of which everything would
later form and most of that matter is
hydrogen and helium so so you start out
for free from the birth of the universe
with the hydrogen and the helium and
these big gas clouds there's there for
free for free that's all wow yeah oh man
this makes me just want to go just be
there when it happens like why can't we
just be there and let the world know
that Chuck wants to be in the room where
it happens
I just want to be here I just want to be
a room where it happens
is that the name of that song what's the
actual name of that song it's from
Hamilton it is from Hamilton I don't
know the name of the song yeah okay
we'll work on it chuck all right I'll
hook you up with the universe one day
yes exactly another uh star talk
explainer good to have you Chuck always
a pleasure four star talk with Neil
deGrasse Tyson keep working
foreign